chers collègues tout d'abord je tiens à
excuser Jean-Marie maison qui est
président de cette mission d'information
sur le bâti scolaire qui est retenu cet
après-midi dans son département pour des
obligations et il m'a demandé de le
représenter j'en suis ravie et très
honorée donc nous poursuivons
aujourd'hui les auditions de notre
mission d'information sur le bâtisse
scolaire avec une table ronde destinée à
entendre le point de vue des entreprises
ce point de vue étant bien sûr
indispensable à notre réflexion c'est
d'ailleurs lors d'un événement organisé
par la Fédération française du bâtiment
que le Président de la République a
évoqué en novembre dernier la nécessité
d'accompagner les communes pour mener à
bien la rénovation thermique des écoles
nous accueillons donc en présentiel au
titre de la Fédération française du
bâtiment monsieur Stéphane Sajou
président du groupe performance
énergétique de la FFB président de la
FFP Île-de-France accompagné de Madame
Léa Lignières
charger des relations institutionnelles
en visio nous avons titre de la
Confédération de l'artisanat et des
petites entreprises du bâtiment Monsieur
David morales vice-président en charge
des affaires économiques Monsieur Alain
chouglia directeur du pôle économique
accompagné de Monsieur Dominique Proust
directeur des relations
institutionnelles de la CAPEB devrait
aussi être connecté oui
au titre de l'Union nationale des
entreprises du paysage Monsieur
Jean-Marc delpeyroux membres de la
commission technique de lunettes
accompagnée de Madame Margot Michaud
chargé des projets techniques à lunettes
et puis compte tenu de l'intérêt que
nous attachons aux espaces extérieurs
sujets que nous avons évoqué la semaine
dernière avec des chefs d'établissement
l'aménagement est en crucial en raison
des risques de canicule nous avons ainsi
souhaité entendre les entreprises du
paysage aux côtés de la FFP et de la de
la PEP donc je vous remercie mesdames et
messieurs de vous être rendus disponible
pour nous cet après-midi je tiens à
apporter à votre attention vous rappelez
nos objectifs les objectifs étant
d'évaluer les besoins de rénovation des
écoles des collèges et des lycées liés à
la transition écologique
d'identifier les défis notamment
juridiques et financiers de cette
rénovation pour les collectivités
territoriales d'évaluer l'efficacité de
l'accompagnement des décideurs locaux
s'agissant plus particulièrement de
l'accès à l'information et à l'expertise
et puis je tenais aussi à vous rappeler
que cette audition donnera lieu à un
compte rendu écrit qui sera annexé à
notre rapport et que son enregistrement
vidéo sera accessible sur le site du
Sénat
donc je crois que vous en avez eu
connaissance un questionnaire vous a été
adressé en amont de cette rencontre nous
n'aurons vraisemblablement pas le temps
d'épuiser tous les sujets qu'il
comportent mais vous pourrez bien sûr
par la suite nous apporter le complément
d'information qui vous paraît
intéressant
dans notre réflexion voilà donc je vais
essayer la parole à notre apporteur cher
Nadège qui va vous poser une première
série de questions et puis nos collègues
bien sûr compléteront par la suite merci
bonjour merci à vous d'avoir pris le
temps de venir nous rencontrer
Madame la vice-présidente l'a rappelé on
a on est sur un sujet important qui
concerne 12 millions d'élèves en fait
chaque année et donc nous avons besoin
de vous pour aborder en fait ce sujet
pour avoir un point de vue très concret
des entreprises appelées à mettre en
œuvre les projets des collectivités les
ambitions de notre pays en manière de
rénovation énergétique du bâti tertiaire
à l'étendue du parc scolaire pose la
question de la capacité déjà de la
filière à répondre à une demande
potentiellement croissante qu'il
s'agisse de la disponibilité des
entreprises ou des matériaux mais
également de la formation de tous les
intervenants à ces questions et
également à l'empreinte environnementale
des rénovations qui seront effectuées
compte tenu des besoins dans ce domaine
anticipez vous des difficultés pour
faire face aux commandes s'agissant par
exemple de la disponibilité de
professionnels concernée ou bien par des
matériaux estimez-vous que les
professionnel s du secteur sont
suffisamment formés pour faire face aux
exigences de la commande publique dans
le domaine du bâtis scolaire
aussi pour les premières questions il y
en aura d'autres à suivre qu'est-ce qui
démarre
bonjour à tous notre tour de vous
remercier de nous avoir invité à cette
commission ce que c'est important pour
nous effectivement de vous produire un
certain nombre de points de vue donc moi
je vais parler au titre effectivement de
la Fédération française du bâtiment
Île-de-France et peut-être après si vous
le souhaitez avoir des éclairages
différents en tant que président de la
FMB de français ce qu'on a signé aussi
une convention avec l'Association des
maires de France en Seine-et-Marne
justement sur la thématique de la
rénovation énergétique pour
effectivement accompagner les
établissements de Seine-et-Marne alors
que ça soit les mers ou les EPCI et donc
les bâtiments les bâtiments scolaires
sur cette démarche là autre casquette
aussi à titre particulier
plus exactement je suis vice-président
en charge de la construction dans un
établissement scolaire du Val de Marne
de 1500 élèves où on est en train
effectivement de déployer la rénovation
énergétique la rénovation de bâti
peut-être que ça pourrait aussi apporter
apporter des informations alors
concernant la question précise que vous
vous posez nous notre l'analyse la
suivante c'est que on a déjà vraiment on
a embauché plus de 100000 personnes
voire 120 000 personnes dans le bâtiment
pour faire face à la rénovation
énergétique que je dirais sur déjà tous
les sujets de ma prime rénov ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est que pour nos
adhérents et entrepreneurs qui maillent
le territoire il y a une question de
redressage de marché on voit qu'il y a
un certain nombre de commandes qui
s'épuisent de difficultés sur certains
marchés donc nous notre position c'est
dire que aujourd'hui en termes de
volumétrie d'entreprise en capacité
d'intervenir sur les bâtiments scolaires
sur le maillage du territoire on voit
pas de problème majeur par contre ce qui
pourrait y avoir c'est des freins et des
freins on en reparlera peut-être dans
les questions suivantes concernant la
l'attribution des marchés et le format
des marchés qui pourraient être
contraignants pour permettre à nos
entreprises d'aller sur ce terrain là
donc nous il y a une question de tempo
bien sûr pour recentrer je dirais
l'activité des entrepreneurs qui ont des
redressé leurs compétences on va dire
les compétences sont là il y a pas de
sujets et puis il y a un autre sujet qui
va avec ça c'est on parle quand même de
massification parce qu'il y a des très
gros enjeux de rénovation des bâti avec
beaucoup de travaux à faire et sur cette
ce sujet de la massification je retire
votre attention sur le fait qu'il y a un
maillage des entreprises sur le
territoire qu'elles soient de la FPB ou
de nos confrères de la CAPEB qui est
très important et qui est très difficile
à proximité en fait des des proximité de
ces futurs chantiers de rénovation et
donc ça c'est une capacité aussi qu'on
nos entreprises et nos adhérents
effectivement en étant proche sur le
terrain et avec un maillage qui est
extrêmement bien fait de répondre à
cette demande en termes de compétences
là-dessus il y a pas de il y a pas de
problème et en termes aussi de
volumétrie pour pouvoir répondre à
l'instant T par contre je le répète il y
a des freins je voudrais juste faire une
petite parenthèse en amont on a parlé de
rénovation du bâti ce que l'on voit sur
le terrain c'est que il y a avant la
rénovation du bâti il y a un certain
nombre de d'étapes une technique à
aborder il y a notamment les étapes
techniques qui ont été invités par le
décrétaire et parle de décret bac aussi
qui touche un certain nombre
d'établissements en termes de surface et
où là les premiers gestes à mettre en
place c'est plutôt du pilotage et du
comptage d'usage pour se donner les
moyens ensuite d'identifier
effectivement est-ce qu'on va intervenir
sur le bâti est-ce qu'on va intervenir
sur les usages sur reparamétrer un petit
peu les installations de chauffage et de
confort pour qu'elles soient plus
adaptée au temps d'usage scolaire et
qu'on est moins de déperdition ou de
gaspillage énergétique il y a ce sujet
là qui est un sujet donc technique de
d'approche par étape aussi technique de
ce qui va être à mettre en oeuvre pour
la rénovation énergétique et là on
touche pas simplement au bâtir à
remplacer les fenêtres ou à toucher au
façade ou à mettre en avant un certain
nombre d'isolations l'autre sujet qui
s'invite très précisément sur les les
établissements scolaires c'est un sujet
qui est un petit peu technique mais je
vais faire très simple on a vu avec le
covid
des établissements tout neuf très
performants énergétiques qui ont eu
beaucoup de mal à se chauffer parce que
quand on était au niveau du covid il
fallait ouvrir les fenêtres au moins une
demi-heure à intervalles réguliers pour
reventiler les salles de classe et cet
hiver on a vu qu'on avait des
installations qui avaient du mal du coup
à poursuivre en chauffage ça ça pose
clairement la question dans les actes de
travaux à mettre en œuvre la question de
la ventilation qui est extrêmement
importante pour les pour les locaux pour
les établissements scolaires il y a bien
sûr une nécessité de renouvellement
d'air qui est très importante parce que
quand vous avez une trentaine d'élèves
et un professeur dans une salle de
classe clairement bah il faut pas que le
taux de CO2 monte et la pratique
d'ouverture des fenêtres va devoir se
poser de manière différente et il y a
des gestes de travaux qui concernent
plutôt cette fois la ventilation de la
ventilation du blofu avec des systèmes
simples parce que si c'est compliqué on
parle dans des contraintes de
maintenance importante donc il y a cette
question là à se poser et puis il y a
une question il y a une question aussi
sur une dérive des températures
on voit que pendant les vacances
estivales les
par le passé avant avant tout ce qu'on a
appris encore avec le rapport du GIEC on
avait des températures qui commençaient
à monter au mois de juillet et là on
voit de plus en plus et c'était le cas
l'année dernière des températures qui
commencent à monter dès le mois de mai
dès le mois de juin avec des élèves qui
sont encore donc dans l'établissement
scolaire et du coup une problématique de
température de confort justement qui
invite aussi une réflexion sur la partie
de rénovation thermique qui se pose pas
simplement sur le sur la partie
chauffage mais aussi sur la partie du
confort thermique été donc voilà c'est
ces sujets techniques sont aussi assez
importants pour pouvoir appréhender
la volumétrie et l'action de nos
entreprises sur ces sur ces sujets là
voilà et puis après on concernant les
acteurs de marché effectivement quand on
en reparlera peut-être après dans les
questions
suivantes mais là il faut il faut il va
falloir bien encadrer les choses sur et
préparer les choses sur les conditions
d'attribution des marchés et sur le type
de marché notamment se méfier beaucoup
des CPE des contrats de performance
énergétique qui peuvent automatiquement
écarter alors je finis de répondre du
coup à votre première question qui
pourrait écarter les entreprises locales
qui ont les compétences qui ont les
disponibilités pour travailler sur le
terrain mais qui n'auront pas je dirais
une suffisance financière ou une
approche financière ou une structure
juridique qui pourront les engager
directement sur des CPE et du coup on
réinviterait je dirais sur ce sur ces
sur ces marchés là des très grands
opérateurs qui ont la surface financière
les possibilités assurantielles mais qui
est devront faire appel à la
sous-traitance avec des marchés
compliqués on y reviendra peut-être tout
à l'heure voilà sur la première élément
de réponse que je peux vous donner
je suis entrepreneur du paysage donc
depuis 30 ans et donc j'agis au niveau
de la commission technique de lunettes
donc lunettes rapidement on va pas
parler de chiffres mais en fait c'est
quand même l'organisation unique
professionnelle donc qui reconnu par les
pouvoirs publics voilà donc nous sommes
plus de 31 000 entreprises du paysage et
donc et plus de 122 actifs en termes
d'entreprise
voilà donc en fait juste pour répondre
rapidement comme frein d'un point de vue
technique on n'a pas réellement de frein
puisqu'en fait nos entreprises
sont en fait sont compétentes dans
beaucoup de domaines notamment dans la
connaissance du sol la place de l'eau
et nous timon au niveau des
végétalisation des bâties voilà donc
techniquement par rapport à ce que pour
rebondir au problème de des pics de
chaleur je veux dire nous notre notre
demande c'est en fait d'intervenir le
plus rapidement
dès la l'étude et des la conception des
projets et en fait de devenir parti
prenante et ne pas intervenir qu'à la
fin pour faire un plaisir voilà donc on
aimerait tout simplement que notre c'est
pas que notre métier soit soit reconnu
puisque on sait pourquoi on est là
mais pour nous il faut que il faut qu'on
ait conscience que le végétal et la
solution à part entière
et en fait que le végétal est
indispensable et n'est pas juste une
variable d'ajustement ça veut dire que
quand on arrive à la fin de chantier on
trouve de malheureuse réservations et
pour nous faire plaisir on va dire on va
planter un arbre voilà donc
comme frein uniquement je dis vous pour
répondre vraiment la question
je ne vois pas enfin il y a certes il y
a d'autres freins puisque mais après
d'un point de vue technique on a
l'habitude de travailler avec les
entreprises de du bâtiment on a
travaux avec les entreprises de travaux
publics
on a des structures qui sont on va dire
pas
identique en terme de volume d'affaires
mais en termes d'organisation on est on
va dire on se ressemble beaucoup et
d'ailleurs tous les projets qu'on fait
sont toujours avec une entreprise de
travaux publics ou du bâtiment donc en
termes de réalisation je veux dire
travailler même dans la main avec avec
les entreprises du bâtiment pour nous ce
n'est pas une nouveauté et pour nous
c'est ça peut être mieux dans tous les
cas
voilà je sais pas si
je peux aussi rentrer un peu plus dans
le technique puisque par rapport
toujours par rapport au frein donc notre
profession est relativement vaste mais
elle est toujours autour du végétal
c'est à dire que on va pas faire du
dallage pour faire du dallage on va pas
faire un stabiliser pour se faire
plaisir faire un stabiliser nous on est
toujours dans l'accompagnement du
végétal le but c'est de verdir de
récupérer les eaux de les filtrer de les
prendre s'en servir de créer des citerne
de récupération d'eau pour arriver à la
finalité c'est du vert du vert pourquoi
parce que comme vous l'avez dit là tout
de suite enfin tout à l'heure
on respire pas on manque d'ombre et par
bonheur on a le végétal l'arbre qui est
un élément fantastique puisqu'en fait il
produit pour lui de l'eau il produit de
l'oxygène on peut respirer il produit si
de l'ombre et c'est le seul élément qui
s'auto régénère qui ne polluent pas
puisqu'en fait on peut l'utiliser en fin
de sa vie on peut toujours l'utiliser il
se recycle entièrement et il produit du
carbone et du bois c'est quand même
magnifique
et par rapport à ça justement on a un
rôle à jouer dans cette mission
un rôle auprès des
établissements auprès des élèves pour
accompagner nos projets pour qu'ensuite
les questions de oui mais le vert c'est
salissant on met de la terre dans les
classes forcément on est on n'est pas là
on n'est pas des on est on est on est
des paysagistes on a des alternatives
des au niveau technique où je pourrais
parler pendant comme vous pendant très
longtemps sur toutes les possibilités
techniques que l'on offre notre notre
secteur pour pour justement aller vers
le vers le vers la biodiversité et vers
le durable et pour justement permettre à
mieux respirer
donc
juste pour terminer cette première phase
donc oui on a je pense qu'on a on a
notre place à jouer et on est là pour ça
c'est c'est aussi pour vous le montrer
et pour montrer notre motivation mais
c'est surtout pour c'est l'occasion que
vous nous donnez déjà cette table ronde
le prouve c'est que d'être au début de
la discussion pour nous ça sera le ça
sera une bonne chose même si on est
toujours en contact je veux dire on
découvre pas dans c'est pas un métier
que l'on découvre puisque moi on est en
tant que professionnel j'ai déjà
participé à
l'aménagement de cours d'école de
collège puisque dans notre département
c'est c'est souvent le Conseil général
soit pour le lycée la région qui nous
demande d'intervenir par différentes
procédés donc on connaît les enjeux et
aussi les interlocuteurs
on va laisser la parole de représentants
de la CAPEB on vous écoute
[Musique]
merci merci bonjour Merci
de travaux sachez que à la CAPEB et un
règle générale et les artisans du
bâtiment
sont désireux de participer aux travaux
de rénovation énergétique qui sont mis
en place parce que on sait pertinemment
que ces objectifs qui sont fixés
pour le futur on ne les attendait pas on
ne les attendra pas sans nous
économiquement on peut dire aussi que
c'est des travaux potentiels donc on se
veut participant chez les particuliers
mais comme un plan a été mis en place et
il y a eu des annonces du président de
la République pour les bâtiments
scolaires sachez que les artisans règle
générale et vous devez sans doute le
savoir puisque vous êtes tous élus et
ils interviennent sur les petites écoles
sur les petites communes et pour
certains en moindre mesure dans les
écoles plus grandes les collèges et les
lycées mais bon ce qui est
vraiment marqué pour les artisans du
bâtiment c'est des chantiers de petites
de petites tailles et certaines fois
pour ceux qui sont un peu plus organisés
sur des marchés publics on estime à la
CAPEB que un artisan sur scène répond à
des marchés publics et deux artisans sur
scène travail avec les collectivités
locales souvent ça marchait public parce
que c'est des gens qui sont dans la
proximité
les autres pourraient intervenir dans
les marchés et vous allez parler de
frein et je pense qu'ils ça fait partie
des des frênes c'est que nous à La
Capelle on travaille pour que il y ait
un maximum d'artisans qui répondent au
marché
mais la problème la problématique si
vous voulez c'est que les artisans sont
réticents et ils ont peur de répondre à
des marchés publics et en règle générale
ça fait pas partie de ce qu'ils
affectionnent particulièrement on a je
crois tous ensemble à faire un grand
travail pour que il est plus artisans
qui répondent et pour qu'on puisse être
beaucoup plus présent surtout ces
marchés de rénovation énergétique et
particulièrement dans les bâties
scolaires ça c'est important on y
travaille beaucoup nous à la cape je
pense que le chiffre de de 5000 euros
qu'on a mis aussi d'aller marcher public
qui permet de pouvoir faire des marchés
un peu plus densité
ça permet aux artisans de plus être
présent dans ces marchés là et c'est
hyper important après vous avez parlé de
de formation moi je parlerai plutôt de
compétences et je pense que et nous
pensons à la CAPEB que comme l'a dit mon
collègue de la fédé
on maîtrise nos métiers nos métiers on a
des compétences on a des compétences
dans le domaine de la rénovation
énergétique c'est plus des compétences
de leur domaine de la réponse au marché
public qu'on a besoin d'avoir
par contre il est clair que comme pour
toutes les professions on a des mises à
niveau super régulière des évaluations
des évolutions à avoir et ça on l'a
toujours fait au fil de l'eau on
s'adapte au marché on s'adapte aux
produits on s'adapte aux techniques on
le fait depuis toujours la preuve c'est
que moi j'ai un métier je suis plaquiste
et le plaquiste d'aujourd'hui c'est le
plâtrier d'hier et ça prouve bien que
ben on est passé du plâtre
du plâtre coco mettez sur les chantiers
au plâtre qui est préfabriqué et qu'on
pose sur les chantiers on fait aussi
beaucoup d'isolation et dans nos métiers
on est passé de l'isolation
traditionnelle l'isolation bio sourcée
et c'est entraîne d'évoluer grandement
de ce côté là vous nous avez parlé de
frein il y a eu des freins ces derniers
temps qui était aussi des frênes dus à
la disponibilité des matériaux on vient
de passer deux ans là très difficile on
a eu le covid on a eu le configuré qui a
complètement déstabilisé le marché des
matériaux qui a qui a fait augmenter le
prix des matériaux et bon je pense qu'on
a un peu moins de soucis à se faire
aujourd'hui pour tous ces matériaux quoi
que pour certaines technologies on a
besoin de matériaux électroniques qui
viennent de l'étranger et là c'est un
peu difficile
nous sommes les artisans des acteurs de
proximité tout comment mon collègue et
qui parle de des espaces verts tout au
moment mon collègue qui est parisien qui
va parler de de ce qui se passe au
niveau de notre capital on est on est
disponible partout on est dans la
proximité et je pense qu'il est
important de de dire que on est capable
de s'organiser
on l'a prouvé pendant le covid notre
agilité nous a permis de rattraper tout
le temps qu'on avait perdu on est
capable de
même avec des prix qui montent de façon
inconsidérée de garder de garder le cap
et dans les freins pour une entreprise
artisanale je pense que ce qui est
important aussi c'est de pouvoir
anticiper
l'anticipation on reproche aux artisans
de pas être disponible mais un artisan
c'est comme je veux dire je vais prendre
un exemple de quand vous Condens une
voiture aujourd'hui vous êtes capable
d'attendre l'année mais un artisan il
faut être capable de l'entendre de
l'atteindre aussi un mois ou deux pour
pouvoir le faire travailler et d'aller
marcher public il faut je pense et
essayer de faire évoluer les choses de
façon à ce que les entreprises rentrent
plus en amont dans les projets règle
générale on se retrouve à être choisi
dans le marché au dernier moment et
avoir à commencer de suite après alors
il y a certaines entreprises en
secondœuvre qui qui évolue un deux trois
mois bien après mais sur les petits
chantiers ça peut arriver très vite et
puis il y a des entreprises qui
attaquent de suite et je pense que c'est
c'est ça fait partie des choses qu'il
faudrait modifier dans les marchés
publics être beaucoup plus en amont tout
comme quand on parle de numérisation on
parle du BIM aussi si une entreprise
elle rentre au dernier moment elle est
pas capable de savoir tout ce qui s'est
fait en amont et il faudrait changer les
choses de façon à ce qu'on rentre un peu
plus en avant voilà je pense que c'est
c'est ça fait partie des freins que j'ai
pu noter qu'on peut vous donner mais bon
je vais pas monopoliser la parole je
laisse
les mes collègues continuer
bonjour donc Alain chaudegat
CAPEB donc j'ai pas de Visio mais je ne
sont donc je vais m'en excuser je
reviendrai peut-être sur la partie qui
vous semblait vous préoccuper pas mal de
la capacité de l'outil de production à
répondre à la demande
on peut dire que l'outil de production
de du bâtiment donc les entreprises du
bâtiment et en l'occurrence donc les
petites puisque on représente la Capelle
les petites elles ont toujours répondu
présentes quand on va prendre un exemple
par exemple par rapport à ma prime rénov
on est où il y a quelques années un
démarrage à 250000 gestes on est passé
en deux trois ans à 750 000 gestes
toutes les enveloppes ont été consommées
l'outil de production a pu s'adapter il
est agile et répondre donc à la à la
financement de public des ados travaux
et donc c'est effectivement une
évolution au fil de l'eau une adaptation
au fil de l'eau donc il y a pas alors
évidemment si le niveau devait de de
commande devait tripler ça pose un
problème comme d'autres tous les
secteurs d'ailleurs pas plus pour le
bâtiment mais là il y a encore donc de
l'agilité il y a de et on aurait pas
fait les niveaux de croissance que nous
avons vu dans le bâtiment encore en 20
de 2,4 % volume c'est bien que l'outil
est quand même flexible il a répondu à
la demande deuxièmement nous n'avons pas
d'inquiétude en tout cas il n'y a pas de
frontière réelle pour la production en
ce qui concerne la rénovation des
bâtiments publics et la rénovation dans
le privé après il y a des il y a des
organisations de chantier qui sont un
peu différentes mais sur les
savoir-faire on est sur les mêmes
compétences de base donc on considère
nous que
il y a une porosité entre ces marchés en
termes d'intervention pour les
entreprises et qui a pas de blocage et
dès lors que le marché est présent qu'il
est qu'il est organisé comme les
monsieur morales pour pour qu'on puisse
s'y rendre assez facilement une accident
assez facilement il y a aucun problème
pour passer des secteur public au privé
d'autant qu'on reste dans le domaine de
la rénovation donc fondamentalement dans
le reste dans le geste premier du
savoir-faire quoi et puis troisièmement
toujours par rapport à l'outil de
production
nous sommes importants de rappeler que
le les artisans maîtrisent leur métier
et ils évoluent aux femmes de techniques
et il n'y a pas de
distribution c'est une évolution c'est
une évolution qui est ce qui se fait
comme ça par incrémentation donc il y a
pas de rupture donc l'évolution elle est
pas qu'elle est acquise et qu'elle est
assez facile mais elle est naturelle et
l'artisan depuis la nuit des temps il
s'adapte aux évolutions donc et même si
on parle de son projet dans ce projet
dans l'avenir pour la décarbonation de
la continuité de la de la performance
énergétique on va s'adapter mais il y
aura pas de rupture dans dans les
savoir-faire il y a juste une adaptation
aux évolutions donc et ça c'est vrai
pour le pour les écoles comme c'est vrai
pour pour pour l'habitat
privé ou le tertiaire privé donc on a on
pense que l'outil de production n'a ne
présente pas une inquiétude ou un risque
pour pour la commande publique enfin sur
les écoles et
en même temps la compétence qui va avec
et l'outil de formation qui est là pour
qui présente et on pense notamment à
fibat qui forme aux formations
performance énergétique nous n'ont pas
on n'est pas démunis aujourd'hui on a
pas eu de carence pour pouvoir répondre
là aussi aux compétences nouvelles pour
le Perforce énergétique
merci juste avant de passer la parole à
Marie-Pierre qui avait une question je
voudrais revenir sur deux éléments il y
a dans le rapport de marque et qui date
de février 2020 il y a deux
préconisations en fait une préconisation
par rapport au label RGE qui est
délivrée en fait à certaines entreprises
et qui garantit les travaux seront
conformes aux exigences
environnementales mais souvent la
démarche nécessaire pour obtenir ce
label ne conduise-t-elle pas à priver en
fait des entreprises qualifiées qui
peuvent être découragés en fait par la
lourdeur de la démarche pour obtenir le
label et je voudrais également avoir
votre avis sur le fait que les petites
communes sont mal armées pour contrôler
effectivement la qualité des travaux
qu'elle commande en tant que maître
d'ouvrage et qu'elle recourt plus
rarement au CPE et donc les prestataires
étant également moins intéressés par les
contrats de petite taille en milieu
rural avoir votre avis sur ces deux
éléments et ensuite Marie-Pierre si tu
veux bien poser ta question
moi je voulais revenir sur toujours le
patrimoine et dans le cadre de la
commission culture nous avons beaucoup
travaillé sur la nécessité de prendre un
peu plus en compte les spécificités du
bâti ancien dans les politiques de
rénovation énergétique ce qui concerne
aussi les bâties scolaires est-ce que
vous considérez que les entreprises qui
font ces travaux sont outillés informés
sur le sujet est-ce que vous proposez
pour votre part en tant que structure à
vos adhérents en expertise sur le sujet
par exemple en lien avec les acteurs du
patrimoine c'était peut-être une
question que vous aviez après donc ça va
et une liée une question aussi par
rapport aux problématiques de sécurité
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup de travaux
dans le bâti scolaire toujours plus que
c'est ce qui nous intéresse en lien avec
l'amiante le plan risque incendie
merci
et bien pour répondre de notre côté à
votre question sur le patrimoine et je
pense pas que mes confrères de la CAPEB
diront le contraire je pense que nos
entreprises de proximité ont vraiment
une très grande maîtrise de leur métier
et que quand elles interviennent sur du
patrimoine elles sont très impliquées
très engagées et elles ont vraiment le
niveau de compétence qui va sur ces
interventions avec je dirais en plus une
vision augmentée du fait de l'intérêt de
la satisfaction de de participer à la
rénovation sur sur des bâtiments
patrimoniaux donc au tffb c'est très
encadré c'est très valorisé on peut vous
parler des World skills par exemple qui
mettent en valeur tous ces tous ces
métiers vraiment qui touchent la
rénovation de la pierre mais aussi à
tout ce qui est menuiseries à tout ce
qui est sol et qui sont un peu
particulier effectivement à la
rénovation du patrimoine donc de ce côté
là clairement j'ai pas de souci voire
même je dirais je détecte chez mes
confrères des motivations
supplémentaires sur ces travaux par
contre ça demande un encadrement
effectivement c'est la question qui
arrivait un petit peu après un
encadrement un petit peu particulier sur
le séquençage des travaux vous touchiez
au sujet de la sécurité et effectivement
ça réclame aussi d'autres intervenants
que nous acteurs qui réalisent les
gestes de travaux sur les audits
d'amiantes sur les audits effectivement
de plomb puisque quand on est dans ces
situations patrimoniales effectivement
on a toujours ces problèmes là et par
rapport à ce que disait mon confort tout
à l'heure sur la notion d'anticipation
il y a un vrai sujet parce que là je
vous parle d'expérience je disais tout à
l'heure que je réalise des nombreux
travaux là une dizaine de millions
d'euros de travaux sur sur 20 millions
sur cinq ans de rénovation dans un
château dans un château et notamment
pour des problématiques d'accès un peu
personne de méditer réduite quand on
parle d'anticipation c'est sujet là de
d'audit d'amion de plomb doivent être
vraiment anticipé pour que quand les
entreprises nous arrive pour travailler
son consultés pour travailler ces sujets
là soient bien encadrés quelquefois
c'est c'est vraiment pas le cas et les
entreprises arrivent pour commencer le
chantier et là on s'aperçoit que là-bas
il y a du plomb et ainsi de suite et
qu'il va falloir prendre des mesures
conservatoires un petit peu particulière
et puis après vous mettiez le doigt sur
un sujet que j'abordais en filigrane
tout à l'heure qui concernait
effectivement cette température qui
augmente de plus en plus tôt dans
l'année et puis en fait ce temps ce
temps de vacances scolaires qui
attribuait a vraiment à faire des
travaux sur les établissements scolaires
en juillet en août c'est un temps qui
est court qui séquence vraiment qui
cadence vraiment les les qui cadence
vraiment la les interventions de travaux
dans les établissements scolaires et qui
souvent distant un petit peu le planning
en fonction des de la volumétrie des
travaux et ce temps là effectivement il
est cadence un petit peu les travaux et
il reste très compliqué par expérience
de réaliser des travaux en milieu entre
guillemets occupé il y a des conditions
de circulation nos agnons nous ouvriers
sur le chantier de livraison de de
produits deux zones de sécurité deux
bruits aussi qui sont invités sur les
chantiers qui font qu'effectivement
c'est une composante qu'il faut qu'il
faut prendre en compte et qui est pas
qui est pas neutre et on reste
effectivement dans ce sujet un petit peu
de l'anticipation de l'anticipation et
de ce cadencement des travaux qui
s'invite au terme des vacances scolaires
je réponds peut-être tout de suite à la
question à la question RGE et la
question de l'encadrement des travaux
par la petite commune alors je vais pas
répondre complètement RGE bien sûr que
nous est fait B on est très attaché à la
mention RGE ça a été des travaux
conduits de formation et qui ont permis
à nos entreprises de donner une
visibilité sur leurs capacité à
travailler sur les sur les travaux de
rénovation énergétique qui est très
importante pour nous il est hors de
question de se désengager de cette de
cette dynamique là qui doit amener aussi
toutes les garanties pour les maîtres
d'ouvrage de formation on a parlé de
fibat tout à l'heure mais de formation
et de savoir-faire j'y rajoute un j'y
rajoute autre chose c'est que ce qu'on
voit arriver c'est que une rénovation
énergétique réussie c'est une rénovation
énergétique qui a fait collaborer
plusieurs gestes de travaux si on fait
qu'une seule chose dans un seul endroit
on a une performance qui est dégradée et
si quand on travaille tous ensemble que
ça soit les fen que ça soit les
paysagistes aussi que ça soit tous les
gestes de travaux qu'on doit
entreprendre dans une rénovation
énergétique la performance elle est au
rendez-vous si on a bien travaillé
ensemble six mois plombier chauffagiste
et climaticien j'ai pas percé des trous
n'importe comment dans les dans les
doublages et que l'électricien a pas
tout déposé il faut que le bâtiment
réponde à certains normes d'étanchéité à
certaines normes de qualité de finition
pour qu'on puisse être au rendez-vous de
la de au rendez-vous de la de la
performance énergétique en cela la
formation là qui va avec la
qualification RGE ça apporte un certain
nombre de garanties au mètre d'ouvrage
et ça apporte aussi je dirais une pour
les entreprises qui ont qui sont
qualifiées une plus-value de même de de
mise en oeuvre de leur qualifications
professionnelles qui vient qui vient
être recouverte par le RGE concernant la
partie effectivement d'encadrement et de
effectivement de faiblesse un petit peu
de la maîtrise d'ouvrage dans des
petites communes ou effectivement il y a
pas tout un staff c'est pas tout un
bureau pour instruire pour suivre les
chantiers pour avoir une assistance à
maîtrise d'oeuvre ainsi de suite nous on
pense et c'est aussi un sujet que on a
qu'on a prototypé en Seine-et-Marne avec
cette fameuse Association des Maires de
France on pense qu'il y a des acteurs
dans la filière qui sont des acteurs qui
peuvent collaborer avec les acteurs qui
mettent en anglais travaux ce sont par
exemple les architectes et ce sont aussi
effectivement les entreprises qui sont
RGE qui ont aussi capacités à produire
des audits et des diagnostics et puis à
aller valoriser pour les mettre en
oeuvre donc effectivement ça reste un
problème ça reste un problème dans les
dans les petites communes d'avoir de
faire collaborer en fait l'ensemble de
la filière et par exemple en
Seine-et-Marne dans ce dans cette
dynamique là on a invité nos amis
architectes à concevoir un forfait
d'audit contenu en termes de prix il y
en a pour il y en a pour 1500 euros et
eux ils interviennent effectivement un
peu en tant que sachons au niveau du
diagnostic pour dire bon ben voilà sur
le bâti et sur l'usage du bâtiment parce
que ça c'est peut-être quelque chose
dont on va parler mais qui est ça
s'appelle la chronotypie qui va
s'inviter aussi dans la suite de la
sobriété énergétique une fois que le
bâtiment est rénové ils ont leur mot à
dire ils sont sur le territoire pour la
plupart ils sont déjà intervenus sur sur
ces opérations-là ils sont en proximité
aussi des mers et en collaborant en mode
projet en mode en mode projet filière
avec les entreprises locales on arrive à
faire des belles choses pour pas cher et
à rendre ce service je dirais cette
maîtrise et cette analyse et cette
sécurité pour des petits maîtres
d'ouvrage qui soit sûr de faire les bons
gestes au travers d'un diagnostic qu'on
leur a proposé qui soit sûr de de bien
choisir les travaux au bon prix et ce
qui va falloir faire avec effectivement
l'oeil aussi de de d'architecte qui sont
qui semblent avoir de la pétanque pour
nous rejoindre sur ces sur ces sujets là
voilà le corpus de la de la réponse que
je peux vous que je peux vous produire
sur cette problématique vraiment de
petits établissements ou effectivement
il est difficile pour pour un maire ou
pour un chef d'établissement d'engager
les bons travaux la meilleure façon de
façon efficiente
merci on pourra avoir une copie de votre
convention
merci beaucoup monsieur morales tout à
l'heure alors je sais pas si vous avez
des choses à rajouter sur cette chose
j'allais rajouter une une autre question
Malaisie je vous en fait je veux le
patrimoine
il faut pas le voir simplement sous le
sous la façade de du patrimoine il y a
aussi la rénovation du bâti ancien
généralement on vous a parlé de
proximité des entreprises artisanales du
bâtiment sont
compétentes et interviennent en règle
générale sur les bâtiments de toutes les
périodes de construction et connaissent
les particularités les particularités de
chaque construction par région je sais
que chez moi on construit et on a
construit de vieux bâtiments d'une
certaine façon quand on les iso il faut
les il faut les isoler de façon à ce que
les murs puissent se respirer il y a des
régions où on construisait différemment
et là aussi c'est c'est la connaissance
du patrimoine habituel sur lequel on
travaille dans notre région qui permet
de pouvoir faire une rénovation
énergétique c'est hyper important c'est
que il faut bien connaître comment sont
faites les constructions comment elles
ont été
aménager au fil du temps pour pouvoir
faire les bons travaux de rénovation
énergétique après dans le domaine du
patrimoine bien sûr comme la télé
revenant nous aussi des gens qui sont
spécialisés mais voilà c'est c'est plus
de mon intervention pour vous dire que
il y a pas que le patrimoine il y a
aussi le bâti ancien et le bâti ancien
c'est important de le connaître et c'est
important de savoir ce qu'on peut y
faire parler de sécurité c'est vrai que
quand vous parlez de l'amiante et du
plomb les audits en amont les études
normalement elles sont faites c'est
c'est bien par contre quand on parle de
sécurité et qu'on parle des décolles
quand on parle de collège de lycée pour
en avoir fait moi pas mal
il y a des moments où on travaille en
milieu habité je vais dire occupé parce
que habiter dans un collège je crois que
des fois il y a des il y a des internats
la sécurité elle est importante parce
que justement on continue à travailler
avec du monde autour c'est hyper
important il y a aussi beaucoup de bruit
c'est pas évident de travailler pendant
un prof fait une place éventuellement
pas loin de là il y a aussi des
problèmes
d'insalubrité de poussière etc je pense
que la sécurité il faut l'étendre un peu
plus dans ce milieu vraiment particulier
parce que quoi qu'on fasse on n'est pas
toujours en capacité de faire des
travaux pendant les vacances et des fois
on se retrouve à chevauche avec le
milieu occupé et dans la sécurité c'est
plus important surtout que là en plus on
a des enfants
après vous avez parlé du découragement
le découragement je pense que dans les
collectivités
dans les petites collectivités il faut
pas avoir peur faut pas avoir peur j'ai
été élu moi
par le passé il existe des structures à
départementales il existe des structures
régionales qui sont là pour les appuyer
et puis vous savez il y a France rénov
aussi normalement France rénov c'est
pour les particuliers mais je pense que
les contacts qu'on les maires et les
élus des communes avec tout tout ce
réseau qui s'est mis en place pour aider
les particuliers
ils accueilleront avec grand plaisir je
pensais mais je vais peut-être je me
trompe mais voilà je pense que voilà il
y a quand même un certain nombre de
choses qui permettent aux petites
collectivités d'avoir peut-être pas la
compétence mais d'abord un appui de
compétences autour d'eux et puis il y a
aussi des entreprises qui sont RGE des
entreprises qui sont prêtes aussi à les
aider dans leur commune ou pas loin de
leur commune
je pense en dernier à vous parler de du
RGE des marchés de la performance
énergétique qui qui sont aidés parce que
être RGE c'est surtout pouvoir répondre
à un marché de performance énergétique
et des soit par ma prime rénov soit par
des certificats d'économie d'énergie et
ce que nous on demande et qui est
qui est primordial c'est il faut amener
de la pétanque aux entreprises
artisanales et aux entreprises en règle
générale pour aller sur des chantiers ma
prime rénov et des certificats économes
d'énergie et de nos jours c'est pas
simple c'est trop compliqué c'est pas
engageant et il faut vraiment que tous
ensemble on travaille pour avoir une
meilleure image et donner une meilleure
image de ces travaux ma prime rénove
certificat d'économie d'énergie pour
qu'il y ait plus d'entreprises qui
s'engagent vers la rénovation
énergétique je me suis amusé à faire un
petit calcul rapide c'est pas des
statistiques mais si on regarde le
nombre d'entreprises qui a artisanale en
France et si on met de côté certaines
entreprises qui font jamais de
rénovation énergétique on a simplement
25% d'entreprises qui pourraient être
RGE qui 25% d'entreprises qui sont RGE
dans le le contexte de la rénovation
énergétique 25% des gens qui sont
capables de faire de la rénovation
énergétique c'est pas suffisant il faut
qu'il faut qu'on monte ces chiffres et
je pense que
la simplification et puis donner la
pétance et donner des exemples avec ma
prime rénove qui fonctionne bien des
certificats d'économie d'énergie qui
fonctionne bien ça donnera envie et les
gens qui feront une rénovation
énergétique chez le particulier ils
seront automatiquement vers les écoles
et les lycées les collèges allez j'ai
oublié quelque chose
merci David alors peut-être non non
peut-être j'aurais peut-être un petit
complément
et et sur peut-être enfoncé le clou à
nouveau sur ce que disait aussi le
monsieur de la FFB par rapport à la
nécessité de travail ensemble on a
énergétique quand les métiers quand les
corps d'état mais aussi les autres
professions les architectes
travaillent ensemble puisque
la performance se fait sur la bonne
interface des actions donc ça c'est
essentiel ce qui me conduit à revenir
sur un point que vous avez soulevé si
vous avez un point c'est la question la
maîtrise d'oeuvre pour les les écoles
etc il est indispensable de bien définir
les CCTP c'est à dire les cahiers des
clauses techniques particulières qui
sont faits par la maîtrise d'oeuvre
parce que les petites entreprises elles
ont pas forcément
intercir technique très développé elles
savent très bien travailler mais il leur
faut quand même
un cahier des charges qui soient précis
avec des plans avec des notices avec des
notices techniques avec des schémas et
leur permet de gagner beaucoup beaucoup
de temps et d'efficacité dans
l'exécution dans les travaux donc ça
c'est vraiment un point à me semble-t-il
à bien mettre en évidence la bonne
définition des sociétés
tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit mais je reviens sur je
reviens sur effectivement la difficulté
d'avoir une maîtrise d'oeuvre pour des
petites communes qui sont pas équipées
qui sont donc pas équipés non plus pour
mettre en place des CCP et donc ça
invite ce que je vous disais cette
possibilité de
faire venir les architectes autour de la
table aussi moi ce que je vois aussi
c'est qu'il y aurait peut-être une autre
idée qu'on pourrait imaginer c'est qu'on
sait que depuis quelques temps on va
avoir la possibilité pour la rénovation
énergétique d'utiliser un tiers
financeur sur une expérience
inexpérimentation de 5 ans je pense que
pour ces petits projets où il y a un
défaut effectivement de de de ressources
un défaut de ressources sur la maîtrise
d'oeuvre je pense que le tiers
financement pourrait répondre à deux
critères déjà un critère de cadrage
c'est-à-dire d'avoir des dossiers de
tiers financement qui soit opératif pour
des travaux qui sont du coup repasser un
petit peu à la moulinette par le par le
tiers financeur ça pourrait amener déjà
un premier cadre pour aider des
des petites mairies effectivement à se
diriger vers vers les travaux qu'ils ont
à faire et puis deuxièmement ça leur
apportera une solution de financement
aussi parce que il y a un vrai sujet sur
les territoires qui nous est remontés
par par notamment les mers bien sûr sur
leurs problématiques d'avoir
des volumes des des mètres carrés des
mètres carrés à rénover et de pas savoir
comment l'aborder au niveau financier
vous êtes super dans l'actualité parce
que on a on a voté le tiers financement
il y a moins d'une heure je crois voilà
donc c'était tout à l'heure à 14h30
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de
difficultés de répondre sur sur les
marchés publics pour certaines
entreprises
comment faire en fait pour pouvoir
encourager les entreprises d'artisanales
à répondre à ses commandes est-ce que
vous avez des remarques des gestion
concernant la commande publique et de
quelles contraintes spécifiques
représentent-elles de votre point de vue
les commandes liées à la réhabilitation
d'écoles collèges ou lycée pour les
entreprises par rapport au chantier de
réhabilitation des autres bâtiments
tertiaires publics ou privés
je sais pas qui répond au premier
monsieur ça joue
très bien merci moi je dirais que sur la
commande publique je sais que montrer en
fait ma réponse sur deux sur deux
chapitres le chapitre du fonctionnement
et des dysfonctionnements de la commande
publique et du paiement de la commande
publique aujourd'hui et puis un deuxième
segment sur quel serait les aménagements
effectivement qui pourraient être de
nature à améliorer je dirais comme
disait mes confrères tout à l'heure
l'envie de petites entreprises de
répondre à de la commande publique les
dysfonctionnements c'est clair
aujourd'hui toutes nos toutes nos
entreprises ont des problèmes de
trésorerie et il faut se dire très
clairement et la FIB le dit très
clairement il y a un certain nombre
d'aménagements de protection de la
commande de des entreprises par la
commande publique ont été mises en
oeuvre on a parlé du seuil des 100.000
euros on a parlé du gel des pénalités on
a parlé des des révisions de prix aussi
qui s'invitaient pour nous accompagner
sur les problématiques de prix des
matériaux donc clairement aujourd'hui on
a vraiment
la première base de de réalisation
l'augmentation du seuil des 30% aussi
d'avance à la commande qui doit être
vraiment revalorisé remis en avant et
qui protège les entreprises derrière ça
clairement il y a des gros problèmes de
fonctionnement moi je suis entrepreneur
j'ai une entreprise de 100 personnes
pendant 6 mois j'ai attendu un acompte à
la commande sur sur une commune du 95
parce que il y a des problèmes de
dysfonctionnement sur chorus pro des
problèmes de complexité à la virgule de
certaines régions ou communes ou
départements qui rajoutent un logiciel
pour charger chorus et qu'on soit payé
la réalité c'est que nous tous
entrepreneurs autant qu'on est on est
maintenant situation de travaux et qui
va derrière il peut se passer deux trois
mois avec 50000 dans mon cas c'était 600
000 euros d'or pendant plus de six mois
alors que c'était le paiement d'une
avance à la commande donc on voit bien
que là il y a vraiment une question à se
poser sur le fonctionnement
aujourd'hui de la commande publique les
outils sont en place qui sont vraiment
je trouve bien calibré on a d'autres
idées je vais vous je vais vous en faire
part aussi mais clairement il y a un
très gros problème de de
dysfonctionnement ou de fonctionnement
qui est pas adapté par rapport à la
volonté du de
nos gouvernants de de nous aider donc là
il y a un vrai sujet il faut pas passer
à côté parce que ça ça fait partie et je
pense pas que mes confrères de la
caverne diront le contraire ça fait
partie des complexités alors déjà il
faut une reprise un petit peu structurer
pour pouvoir cocher toutes ces cases se
mettre sur corail c'est ainsi de suite
c'est pas c'est pas évident pour toutes
toutes les entreprises mais il y a ce
problème de dysfonctionnement il y a
aussi des problèmes de dévoiement je
m'explique dans la commande publique
vous avez pris la précaution
effectivement nous autorisez à
bénéficier d'indices de révision de prix
ça touche à la problématique d'évolution
des prix dont on parlait tout à l'heure
sur les matériaux qui montrent qu'ils
descendent ainsi de suite qui font
souffrir les entreprises
clairement si moi aujourd'hui je suis
sous-traitant d'une entreprise générale
ou d'une entreprise un peu plus grosse
que la mienne qui va prendre le marché
que je sous-traitant technique de cette
entreprise elle va signer en marché
public avec une clause de révision de
prix et moi je n'en bénéficierai pas
parce que je suis entre j'ai un marché
privé de deux secondes par rapport à
cette entreprise là et ça c'est un vrai
problème parce que la volonté publique
de protéger les entreprises et de pas
paupériser le tissu des entreprises sur
le territoire national n'est pas
respecté par ce biais là donc c'est un
truc vous voyez c'est un peu un effet de
bord mais ces effets de bord font que
l'image de la commande publique sur je
vais avoir je vais avoir du temps pour
me faire payer alors après ouais j'ai le
droit de réclamer les intérêts
moratoires mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire c'est pas c'est pas le sujet c'est
pas c'est pas de ça dans ton parle donc
deux sujets là il y a vraiment il y a
vraiment quelque chose à regarder de
très près et puis après on passe sur le
chapitre plutôt d'aménagement
particulier qui pourrait être qui
pourrait être aussi env surtout ces
travaux on a des retenus de garantie des
retenues de garanties pour couvrir des
du parfait achèvement pour tous ces
sujets là ça coûte de l'argent à
l'entreprise parce que c'est des
cautions qu'on en a à la banque avec des
frais financiers qui grimpent pour
rideau je vous fais pas de dessin avec
ce qui se passe en ce moment donc
clairement il y aurait des il y aurait
une étude amener pour se dire peut-être
qu'on pourrait réduire de 5% à 3% c'est
retenu de garanties et faire en sorte
que leur condition de délivrance comme
les paiements des DGD soit un petit peu
plus sur un petit peu plus rapide
automatique
dans ce contexte là et puis on a aussi
la question de du paiement direct de
certains sous-traitants quand on est
dans des travaux de rénovation
énergétique qui embarquent plusieurs
entreprises il y a possiblement un
mandataire possiblement une entreprise
qui va prendre le lead et puis être
accompagné par par des artisans sur
différents gestes de travaux remplacer
des fenêtres poser une pompe à chaleur
ou je ne sais quoi clairement
aujourd'hui ça sera intéressant d'avoir
un seul qui soit beaucoup plus bas pour
que les entreprises qui interviennent en
second rang techniquement puissent
bénéficier d'un paiement direct de la de
la commande publique donc vous voyez il
y a ces deux aspects sur la commande
publique à la fois enfin je dirais trois
aspects à la fois un chapeau qui dit
clairement il y a beaucoup de choses qui
ont été faites et qui bénéficiaient la
protection des entreprises et ça il faut
vraiment s'en féliciter le dire haut et
fort mais derrière ça il y a un gros
problème parce que ça fonctionne très
très mal sur les territoires ça
fonctionne très très mal et puis après à
la marge il y a peut-être aussi ben
encore des curseurs à pousser notamment
sur les cautionnements de retenue
garantie ça touche aussi à la question
du marché de la du contrat de
performance énergétique
si la commande publique s'embarque à
passer ou à demander à ses opérateurs
locaux de passer des contrats de
performance énergétique pour le moindre
geste de travaux tout le monde est mort
je sais pas comment une petite
entreprise comme celle qui sont sur le
territoire chez nous ou celle de nos
confrères ou à un maire petit maître
d'ouvrage au sens où il a pas beaucoup
de travaux à faire va pouvoir se pencher
sur un apex un CAPEX sur un roi c'est
même pas la peine d'y penser quoi ça ça
ne se fera pas et en même temps ça va
centrifuger l'ensemble des opérateurs
locaux qui sont en capacité de mettre en
ordre leurs compétences de réadresser
leurs compétences sur ces travaux là
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on demande dans
un contrat de performance énergétique
c'est de s'engager sur une durée de
temps qui n'est pas à l'échelle de temps
de nos petites entreprises sur le la
performance de prendre le risque de le
prendre le risque de se de d'une
consommation énergétique qui serait pas
dans les clous du départ du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on invite autour de la
table on invite des assureurs ou des
grandes sociétés de maintenance qui
elles ont cette surface financière en
cette visibilité globale et là par
contre les prix c'est pas les mêmes et
les ressources les ressources ils vont
être obligés de toute façon de venir les
chercher chez nous et tout le monde tout
le monde va tout le monde va y perdre
donc je dis méfiant sur le contrat de
performance énergétique parce que c'est
un bon support ça on se dit bah voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on va financer les
travaux ainsi de suite mais moi je pense
aussi que le tiers financeur pourra
avoir cette compétence sur effectivement
sur le contrat de performance
énergétique pour regarder ces questions
de roi d'apex de CAPEX et permettre au
petit maître d'ouvrage voire au plus
grand maître d'ouvrage d'avoir une
expertise aussi financière sur ces
retours d'investissement et ne pas faire
porter ça par les entrepreneurs ça n'est
pas leur rôle le rôle des entrepreneurs
c'est de bien faire leur boulot pour
répondre à certains critères techniques
qui vont permettre après aux usagers de
bénéficier d'un bâtiment qui sera qui
sera sobre au même titre que vous
achetez une voiture électrique si je
vous apprends pas la conduire il y en a
un qui va faire 20 km avec sa voiture et
il y en a un qui va faire 150 km la
voiture c'est la même quoi donc l'usager
sera invite là dedans et il y a il y a
d'autres supports à mettre en oeuvre sur
ce sujet là désolé je suis un peu long
mais c'est un sujet qui me passionne
merci Monsieur morales
que la voix mais j'ai atteint d'une neuf
mois 40 000 euros alors que tout était
prêt toutes les formalités ont été 40
000 euros 9 mois
sur une commune je vous dirais pas où
c'est
la sous-traitance
mon collègue en a parlé sachez qu'il y a
un projet de loi sur le cascading la
sous-traitance en cascade qui qui va
arriver dans vos mains très
prochainement et je pense que toutes les
problématiques qu'entraînent à la
sous-traitance et qui ont été évoqués
par mon collègue de la Fédération
française du bâtiment on va les
retrouver et derrière je pense qu'il y a
un certain nombre de
changement à faire dans cette façon de
sous-traiter avec la Fédération
française du bâtiment on est peut-être
pas tout à fait d'accord mais peut-être
qu'un jour on sera d'accord sur le
nombre de sous-traitants qu'on peut
avoir parce que vous savez que il peut y
avoir un deux trois quatre cinq six je
ne sais combien de rangs sous-traitance
ce qui amène à des choses complètement
aberrantes et sachez que il y a un
projet de loi qui qui a été préparé vous
demanderait domicile donnera les
éléments si vous voulez les garanties et
les cautions c'est exactement la même
problématique la différence près c'est
que les grosses entreprises elles font
une caution à la banque les petites
entreprises généralement comme les infos
pas souvent mais elle passe un an à
attendre l'argent qu'il aurait dû et
souvent ils sont obligés de téléphoner
ou d'envoyer des courriers parce que
tout le monde oublie cette caution et
oublie de nous rendre par contre ce que
je voulais vous dire c'est que ce qui a
d'important pour les artisans et pour la
commande publique en général c'est que
il faut leur donner de la pétance comme
tout à l'heure je vous ai parlé de la
pétanque pour ma prime rénov et comme je
vous parle d'appétence pour les
certificats économie d'énergie et le RGE
il faut donner de la pétanque aux
artisans et pourquoi les artisans alors
c'est pas ce que dit la cape je me fais
n'importe quoi avec le général des
artisans les communes c'est des mauvais
payeurs
toute façon ils prennent toujours le
moins cher et puis des prix aussi bas
c'est pas possible c'est important c'est
c'est impossible à faire et puis alors
ça c'est la cerise sur le râteau toute
façon c'est pas la peine de répondre
c'est réservé à certains c'est toujours
les mêmes qui ont les marchés voilà il
faut qu'on travaille tous ensemble élu
organisation professionnelle pour
essayer de gommer un peu toutes ces
images pour donner une appétence comme
je vous ai dit il faut donner envie aux
gens il faut donner envie aux artisans
de répondre au marché public et c'est
quand même dommage pour certains
artisans qui habitent dans des communes
qui refont une école qui reformule
cantine tout à l'heure nous avait
demandé des listes là moi j'ai un
certain nombre de
[Musique]
une bonne partie des preuves existants
et puis la deuxième c'est peut-être
optimisé les outils existants en
facilitant la fluidité entre entre les
différentes missions entre les
différentes étapes par exemple et le
plus les deux les deux profils le plus
lourd c'est c'est délai cachés qui
renvoient à
humaine des paiements alors que les
travaux sont terminés depuis très
longtemps donc vraiment fluidifier et ça
ça peut donner de l'attractivité c'est
deux choses là peuvent donner de
l'attractivité sans qu'on ait besoin de
pousser les entreprises à aller vers ces
chantiers là parce que deux facto le
code la moyenne de la commande publique
sera attractif donc c'est ça qui nous
semble également importante dans le
quotidien ça c'est quelque chose et ça
demande pas d'argent à l'état puisque il
y a pas investir davantage ça demande
pas de revoir le code de la commande
publique donc déjà si on pouvait
optimiser appliquer optimiser les choses
on gagnerait beaucoup en efficacité sur
ces sur ces chantiers là
j'ai oublié j'ai oublié une chose la
lotissement c'est la première pierre à
mettre en place pour que les artisans
puissent répondre au marché public sans
un lotissement on est foutu
merci Monsieur Sajou voulait rajouter
quelque chose
vous mettre quelque chose dans l'oreille
aussi c'est que clairement tout ce qu'on
est en train de dire c'est que il y a
les compétences et les ressources
locales pour répondre aux besoins et en
même temps il y a une un effet très très
vertueux à être capable avec des marchés
publics effectivement d'attirer et de
faire travailler les gens localement
c'est que mécaniquement on centrifuge
complètement les écho fraudeurs parce
que clairement une entreprise locale qui
croise au marché le lendemain les gens
chez qui elle a fait les travaux ou
l'instituteur ou l'institutrice
forcément ça crée une relation de
confiance et ça crée un engagement qui
est complètement différent qui
naturellement écartent les écofroders
alors que si vous laissez des marchés en
pâture à des sociétés qui seraient
purement commercial d'une part qui
serait pas très voilà qui aurait pas des
une démarche une démarche bâtiment comme
celle que l'on entend
voilà c'est garanti jusqu'à la sortie de
la porte du garage quoi et puis voilà
les entreprises viennent alors on a
parlé de travail détaché on a parlé de
de RGE on a parlé de tout ça vous avez
des entrepreneurs qui qui vont arriver
sur ces marchés là qui vont faire les
choses du bout du bout des lèvres et
encaisser leur première situation et
qu'on verra pas donc il y a aussi une
grande vertu à être en capacité de
mettre en face des entreprises locales
des marchés de la commande publique
locale c'est ce que je voulais ajouter
je pense que ça vaut pour vous j'imagine
ça vaut aussi pour pour nous bien sûr et
je me permets de rebondir par rapport
justement l'alotissement je pense que
d'avoir des des lots bien scindés c'est
quand même enfin la solution à un bon
travail puisqu'en fait chaque eau
maîtrise bien son chantier et donc je
pense que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
une solution voilà je m'attarderai pas
trop juste que dans notre métier pour
protéger quand même justement les
collectivités les petites collectivités
aussi des maîtres d'oeuvre on a des
règles professionnelles et un fascicule
qui régit notre métier qui a été
complètement remanié et se fascicule 35
qui était très obscur à l'époque
justement parce qu'il y avait quatre
lignes pour expliquer en fait tout le
travail qui a fait et justement a été
complètement remanié et du coup les
devis sont très explicites il y a par
contre beaucoup plus de travail
puisqu'il y a beaucoup plus de lignes ça
veut dire que le
maître d'ouvrage je veux dire avec un
maître d'oeuvre encore mieux mais ne
serait-ce que par cette nouvelle
formalisation
je dirais il est quand même beaucoup
plus rassuré moi je terminerai juste par
rapport je revenais par rapport
à la protection du patrimoine même si on
n'est pas lié au bâtiment proprement dit
on y a tout ce qui est environ le
bâtiment notamment les arbres les les
édifices les tout ce qui est en place
notamment le sol et que on a des chartes
au niveau au niveau des des
collectivités
je noterai quand même la charte de la
ville d'Auch qui est quand même
magnifique concernant la protection
d'arbres remarquable et toute la
contrainte et aussi le ce qui peut se
passer en cas de de brides ou de
branches voilà et d'où les protections
qui sont mis en oeuvre donc tout ça ce
sont des éléments de protection aussi de
donc de
donc des collectivités des décideurs
voilà je ne mourrais pas
dans ces chantiers aussi l'intervention
de l'architecte de France aussi qui
interviennent notamment pour protéger
pour bien voir que la végétation reste
bien adéquation avec le bâtiment
notamment quand c'est des bâtiments
musicien et ainsi de suite mais attendez
pas plus alors moi je me permets de
rebondir si vous le voulez bien et
revenir sur l'aménagement des espaces
extérieurs et notamment le travail des
paysagistes à l'épreuve de la transition
écologique est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler nous dire comment vos missions
s'articulent ce coordonnent avec les
professionnels du bâtiment avec
avec les entreprises les artisans ou
même avec des architectes alors
justement je reviens à l'aloutissement
disons que tout simplement quand on a
plusieurs lots les choses sont
naturellement simples puisque vu qu'il y
a plusieurs lots nous avons la plupart
du temps un chef d'orchestre qui est un
maître d'oeuvre paysagiste
issu
plutôt oui paysagiste la plupart du
temps et donc
là les choses sont relativement simple
puisque nous avons notre lot et ensuite
donc le travail est facile à réaliser
ensuite comme on a pu en discuter tout à
l'heure il y a la sous-traitance et dès
qu'il y a de la sous-traitance bon
bah disons qu'on a on va on va revenir
au problème que l'on vient de voir
actuellement c'est à dire donc des
intermédiaires des problématiques que
l'on vient de voir voilà
après les relations les plus simples
sont les relations les plus directes
aussi donc nous avons les entreprises
ont la chance de travailler aussi en
direct donc avec la maîtrise de
l'ouvrage sur des chantiers qui sont
réduits qui correspondent à la taille de
chaque structure
ça me fait penser à une autre question
quand peut-être plus
pour vous pour la Fédération du Bâtiment
quand tout à l'heure vous nous avez
parlé des fringues que vous pouvez
rencontrer les difficultés pour faire
face à la commande vous avez parlé aussi
la cape et bladies des difficultés liées
à la disponibilité de matériaux est-ce
que vous avez aussi la difficulté de
disponibilité du personnel de la main
d'oeuvre que ce soit dans vos
métiers respectifs ce qui me concerne on
a les mêmes problématiques ce qui
concerne je veux dire bon les certaines
fournitures notamment le bois mais après
tout ce qui vivent on est aussi régis
par des par de des chartes aussi
notamment le végétal local qui justement
nous rend plus proche de nos régions de
nos départements ça veut dire que mon
collègue de Bretagne mon collègue
d'Alsace n'aura pas la même liste que
que
ça veut dire que sur tous ceux qui
vivent on a de leur activité de la
souplesse toujours pareil quand le
projet est vu à l'avance et qu'il ait vu
dès la la de la conception tout en
découle ça veut dire qu'on peut déjà
choisir les arbres on peut déjà les
mettre en culture et les choses
deviennent naturellement très simple
alors que la sous-traitance c'est de la
Coupe c'est du changement de direction
voilà donc on en revient un petit peu
à la base quoi ça et ensuite surtout des
fournitures bon le on a la problématique
le châtaignier les carences de bois et
ainsi de suite bon voilà d'où la
problématique d'où la nécessité d'avoir
les projets en main très rapidement
vous êtes vous êtes associés assez
rapidement ou c'est l'exception en fait
quand il y a une rénovation de d'un
d'une école d'un collège ou d'un lycée
est-ce que vous arrivez généralement à
être associé assez tôt à cette
réhabilitation ou à cette rénovation ou
c'est l'exception encore où vous êtes
associé plutôt à la fin comment est-ce
que ça se déroule alors je vais parler
personnellement me dire que ça dans mes
collègues au vu de certaines vu aussi
nous dans notre département enfin tout
est bon pour prendre pour être en phase
avec le chantier on a la chance d'être
au contact donc de nous des élus donc
c'est vrai que de manière informelle on
sait ce qui se passe et c'est vrai que
pour nous c'est important ensuite donc
on a la phase des certains marchés qu'on
a notamment à bon de commande qui nous
permettent de se glisser
on va dire dans le marché alors que
alors que on était peut-être pas censé
mais le fait de d'être positionné sur
plusieurs axes nous permet de répondre
mais l'axe le mieux le plus profitable
et certes la discussion et d'être
introduit dès le début du projet alors
sur des petits projets donc sur des
petits pour nous qui sont relativement
importants on a cette chance parce qu'on
est vraiment très proche du client et
sur des projets à venir je vois il y en
a quelques-uns qui sont à venir ce sont
des projets qui sont plus importants
mais qui vont passer tout simplement par
l'appel d'offre
et ça veut dire que vu qu'on passe par
l'appel d'offres comme tout le monde le
sait
soit on reçoit la belle d'offre via la
plateforme ou soit on a la chance
d'avoir certains contacts de savoir que
l'offre va paraître un certain moment et
donc dès qu'elle a c'est un problème de
rapidité pour pouvoir souscrire donc les
les voir sont comme ça l'appel d'offre
public privé
on fait comme tout le monde
sur ce sujet là moi je pense qu'on a on
a des progrès à faire pour travailler
ensemble beaucoup plus tôt sur le sujet
de la rénovation énergétique je vous
donne un exemple là sur le projet dont
je m'occupe qu'elle a la reconstruction
d'une école maternelle et d'une école
primaire sur un budget de 10 millions
d'euros on est tous autour de la table
donc maître d'ouvrage et on part dans un
délire où dans la cour on va mettre de
la brumisation parce qu'il va faire trop
chaud l'été et là on est dans un délire
complet quoi on consomme de la de l'eau
enfin c'est n'importe quoi donc
rapidement on se dit mais on va quand
même effectivement faire venir un
paysagiste pour travailler avec nous sur
ce sujet là qu'on a invité dès l'appel
d'offres des l'appel d'offres sommaire
pour nous proposer des solutions
arborées et du coup avoir un budget qui
était déjà délimité par ce sujet là mais
là je pense qu'il y a vraiment des il y
a vraiment un sujet et c'est une très
bonne idée de de mettre autour de cette
table effectivement nos confrères
paysagistes parce qu'il y a il y a
vraiment une collaboration entre
l'environnement du groupe scolaire et
les solutions
entre guillemets vertes au sens noble du
terme mais au sens pérenne du terme
qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre et la
rénovation du bâtiment parce qu'un
bâtiment scolaire les élèves vivent
dedans et vivent dehors aussi et il y a
vraiment ce sujet là et là pour vous
donner cet exemple c'est c'est du c'est
la réelle politique ça c'est il y a
cette discussion là elle a eu lieu il y
a six mois quoi
[Musique]
effectivement c'est pas le moment
mais moi j'ai l'exemple inverse où on a
construit une école dans ma commune et
effectivement les paysagistes ont été
associés quasi dès le début et ça a
évité en fait avec l'échange avec les
maîtresses et la direction d'école des
une erreur qui était en fait il y avait
un des arbustes qui avaient été choisi
avec des espèces de petites pommes ou
des je sais pas des des je me souviens
plus du nom mais où effectivement les
maîtresses ont réagi tout de suite en
disant mais là ça va pas être possible
parce que les enfants ils vont trouver
ça très drôle c'est rouge c'est autre
mais c'est pas très bon à manger quoi
donc c'est vrai que on a aussi besoin de
l'oeil de l'expert parfois pour pour
éviter ce genre d'écueil et j'avais une
autre question par rapport à
l'industrialisation en fait des
solutions qui pourraient être
préconisées notamment toujours par
rapport à ce rapport des marques sur la
rénovation des bâtiments scolaires en
fait qui indiquent que pour réduire les
coûts et accélérer la rénovation
est-ce que vous semble opportun d'avoir
une orientation et une réalisation
d'industrialisation à grande échelle en
fait
ça soit pas le quotidien des entreprises
artisanales du bâtiment
on va parler de construction à la mort
on va parler peut-être pas
d'industrialisation dans le bâtiment en
grande majorité
quand on fait de la rénovation c'est une
rénovation sur mesure
industrialisation et sur mesure ça va
pas trop bien par contre il y a des
endroits il y a des possibilités où on
peut reproduire sur plusieurs bâtiments
éventuellement alors là je passe on peut
parler de collège ou de lycée
on peut à grande échelle
travailler sur plusieurs bâtiments ou
plusieurs bâtiments de l'établissement
on peut aussi faire des choses à petite
échelle mais bon la grosse difficulté
c'est l'été l'été rogénéité des
constructions tu vas arriver à le dire
je pense que c'est c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'il faut
beaucoup tout le monde se met à la tête
parce que on a beau faire des études on
a beau dire ça va être plus efficace si
on fait de l'industrialisation
une petite industrialisation d'accord
mais une grosse industrialisation on ne
peut pas faire la même chose partout je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de
patrimoine et des particularités de
chaque région avec des matériaux qui ont
été utilisés qui à l'origine sont des
matériaux qu'on trouvait sur place c'est
pour ça que chez moi dans la
Haute-Garonne c'est des pierres plutôt
de la Garonne et dans le Gers un peu
plus haut chez mon collègue des pierres
du Gers voilà c'est ça rire mais c'est
vraiment hyper important de savoir que
c'est tout différent on est jamais sur
la même chose et c'est difficile pour
ces petits pour ces petites rénovations
de parler d'industrialisation après si
je sais pas à midi je parlais avec des
collègues autour de moi de
de ce thème qu'on allait aborder cet
après-midi il y a une de mes collègues
qui habitent en région parisienne et qui
me parlait de plus de 3000 de 3000
élèves dans un dans un lycée avec deux
piscines un truc grandiose pour moi qui
suis de la campagne
mais ce que je dis c'est que là
éventuellement si il y a une un
alignement de bâtiments qui sont
identiques on peut faire une rénovation
énergétique avec quelque chose qui est
refait et qui ressemble un peu à
l'industrialisation mais après dans
toutes les petites communes rurales dans
toutes les communes de France on
retrouve des choses complètement
différentes donc pour moi c'est un peu
différent allez
on parlera peut-être de réplicabilité
dans le sens où on peut mastifier nos
interventions au sens où la
mastification n'est pas
l'industrialisation si on parle du
principe que les artisans les plus
entreprises sont réparties sur
l'ensemble du territoire et qu'ils ont
un effectif important c'est bien la
multiplication des entreprises qui va
faire la masse donc la massification
donc nous nous considérons en tout cas
pour les écoles les groupes scolaires
qui sont assez répartis sur le parce que
auprès de la taille des communes en fait
donc qui sont assez présentes sur le
territoire et moins les lycées qui sont
plus à l'échelle des régions on a une
entrée nous très très naturelle auprès
de des groupes scolaires des des écoles
maternelles primaires etc et donc parce
que la proximité parce que le multiple
donc on est capable de parce qu'on est
nombreux de de répliquer pas mal les
interventions et souvent sur mesure
comme disait de Morlette donc ça c'est
de la mastification sans utiliser le mot
industrialisation qui à notre sens
signifie autre chose
maintenant on peut y travailler
parce qu'on aurait des courbes
d'expérience sur des actions plus
collectives où on s'est groupé on a mis
des mouvements momentanés d'entreprise
de la cotraitance et non pas de la
sous-traitance où là peut-être la
réplicabilité se fera pas au niveau de
quelques d'entreprises qui ont déjà fait
des expériences dont tel ou telle école
d'une petite commune mais où ils ont
fait plusieurs écoles à la taille du
département ils sont groupés etc et donc
là on ne répabilité par par le nombre de
chantiers rassemblés donc on a deux
façons d'être présent à la fois on est
très très proche des communes et des
écoles sont un petit peu presque les
voilà chaque artisan connaît l'école
peut-être même il intervient ou il a pu
aller à l'école lui-même et puis et puis
à un niveau plus élevé quand il se
groupe peut-être faire des chantiers
plus importants ou plus d'écoles parce
qu'ils ont de la côte rétance en
capacité en
complémentarité en expertise et donc
voilà nous les deux les deux pistes en
tout cas que qu'on préconise de
poursuivre et de retenir pour pour
pouvoir massifier donc les rénovations
des écoles et le rapport lui parle
d'industrialisation mais mais au sens où
peut-être
du standard répétitif à grande échelle
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait le cas de
des écoles localement
[Musique]
c'est aussi c'est que nos entreprises
sont capables de travailler en atelier
et en fonction de la taille des des
bâtiments à rénover du nombre de
fenêtres qui auraient à changer par
exemple ou d'un certain nombre de sujets
comme ça nos entreprises sont tout à
fait en capacité d'instruer d'instrueux
d'un disque réalisé excusez-moi leur
propre process pour être plus efficace
effectivement et notamment en regard des
tempos de pose qui sont effectivement
compliquées à gérer avec les vacances
scolaires mais clairement compter sur un
système qui pourrait une solution
globale qui pourrait être invité sur
tous les sur tous les établissements
scolaires on a parlé de patrimoine tout
à l'heure on a des salles de on a des
écoles de deux classes en
pléthory disséminé partout c'est
vraiment pas le sujet quoi ça serait ça
serait inefficace ça prendrait
énormément de temps à monter et
clairement je l'ai expérimenté aussi moi
avec mon entreprise dans les dans les
Hauts-de-France ça fonctionne pas quoi
ça fonctionne pas j'y ajouterai aussi
que en même temps quand on parle de ce
type d'industrialisation
on parle aussi des des fabricants de
matériaux parce qu'en fait c'est eux qui
sont à l'origine aussi de ces
conceptions là pour vendre des matériaux
que ça soit des isolants que ça soit des
process diverses et variés et du coup la
partie de conception et d'adaptation aux
différents bâtis à rénover et ce
savoir-faire qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre
uberise aussi d'une certaine manière
indirectement le tissu local des
compétences locales des ressources
locales de nos métiers qui sont exercés
à proximité des à proximité des des
écoles sur les communes donc clairement
nous notre position là dessus c'est
c'est pas une bonne solution et c'est
encore moins une bonne solution pour
pour la rénovation des établissements
scolaires
merci
c'est une des présentations en fait
quand nos a fait qu'on nous a fait quand
on nous a présenté le rapport de marque
on nous a parlé d'industrialisation qui
avait eu lieu dans les je me souviens
plus du pays non
en fait dans les Pays-Bas ou au Danemark
voilà clairement le process énergétique
était très qui était très novateur il y
a quelques années ça vient effectivement
de des Pays-Bas avec des industriels qui
sont mobilisés pour concevoir des
solutions duplicables sur des maisons en
vente mais résultat des résultats des
courses le résultat n'est pas là quoi le
résultat n'est plus on n'a pas les mêmes
modes constructifs non c'est pas du tout
merci j'ai fait le tour moi de mes
questions est-ce que mes collègues
avaient des questions où je pense que
vous avez été très complet
Gilbert vas-y
le problème de l'entreprise générale est
généralement une question qui se pose au
maître d'ouvrage bon je sais que la
CAPEB
a dans son sein plutôt des entreprises
petites et moyennes
est-ce que
vous avez sur
l'intervention d'entreprise générale
dans vos départements respectifs une
politique qui est une politique de la
part des collectivités qui verse vers
l'entreprise générale ou pas parce que
c'est souvent une question qui se pose
j'ai connu des départements où les
entreprises générales étaient sur les
très gros chantiers généralement la
règle
quand c'est des chantiers moyens salés
quelquefois et d'autres départements où
la règle est plutôt de favoriser par
l'effet du lotissement au moment des
marchés publics de favoriser les
entreprises locales les entreprises qui
généralement ne peuvent pas répondre sur
un marché global sur un gros chantier
alors pour répondre à votre question il
y a une troisième voie sur le
département de la Seine-et-Marne que je
connais bien vous l'avez vous l'avez
compris l'orientation du conseil
départemental notamment pour tous les
travaux qui dirigeante c'est
effectivement de pas confier en priorité
à des entreprises générales de pas
solliciter les entreprises générales
mais plutôt d'aller vers des marchés de
conception réalisation et sa présente
plusieurs avantages chez conception
réalisation parce que ça nativement ça
regroupe les entreprises pour répondre
avec une maîtrise d'oeuvre avec autour
d'un architecte d'un bureau d'étude et
ça regroupe un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont du coup aussi
productrices de solutions et
productrices de leurs propres projets
pour l'emmener à bien et ça nous on
trouve la FFB que c'est une très très
bonne solution parce que ça n'écarte pas
les entreprises générales qui ont du
savoir-faire sur toute la partie
maçonnerie sur toute
leurs travaux mais en même temps ça
invite je dirais un collectif qui est
mandaté qui est qui est consolidé et qui
qui a une existence juridique à répondre
à ces marchés là donc ça ça reste de mon
point de vue une bonne solution et
notamment là on parle de rénovation de
bâtir rénovation énergétique de bâti
c'est clair que quand on a un groupe
scolaire de 1500 élèves à construire
avec avec 25 millions ou 30 millions
d'euros de chantier la question de
l'entreprise généralement elle se pose
parce que là il y a un certain nombre de
garanties de savoir faire des
entreprises générales qui font appel à
nos prestations
à nous tous sous traitant technique de
premier rang où là il y a vraiment du
sens quoi mais sur la rénovation
énergétique je pense qu'il y a autre
chose à faire et je pense que les
marchés de conception réalisation ou des
marchés d'alloutissement sont beaucoup
plus adaptés effectivement sur le le
pourtour de l'île de France on a des
départements qui sont encore très très
qui sollicitent les entreprises
générales pour pour n'importe quel type
de travaux parce que ils ont une offre
globale ils ont une certaine sécurité
financière ils ont des pénalités de
retard qui pourront appliquer les
entreprises générales pourront supporter
si jamais du retard ça amène encore plus
effectivement de de garantie au maître
d'ouvrage qui en réalité dans son pas en
termes de qualité et qui sont pas
réellement au service du projet donc je
reviens sur cette dernière idée c'est
vraiment les marchés de conception
réalisation il y a vraiment du sens pour
la rénovation énergétique à favoriser ce
type d'appel d'offres et à aider on y
travaille beaucoup à la fédé à créer ces
véhicules juridiques le plus simple
possible pour que les entreprises
puissent se grouper répondre à ce type
de marché et tenir leurs engagements
bien sûr les engagements qui sont
attendus pour la maîtrise d'ouvrage
je vais pas je vais pas parler de
conception réalisation mais tout à fait
non non mais justement ça m'a permis de
je vais je vais vous parler de des élus
parce que la question elle était
pourquoi il y a des élus qui choisissent
une façon une autre mais je vais vous
dire assez déjà des élus ils sont comme
leur territoire mais vous devez le
savoir beaucoup mieux que moi il
ressemble à leur milieu à leur milieu et
comme nous nous ressemblons en au milieu
il y a les urbaines et périurbaines les
ruraux avec un accent sans AXA avec des
accents différents et après sur le
terrain il y a des élus qui sont plus ou
moins proches je vais vous dire de la
Fédération française du bâtiment et de
la CAPEB ou alors pas du tout proche des
organisations professionnelles pas du
tout proche des des entreprises et il y
en a certains qui sont qui sont initiés
qui savent qu'elle est quel est le
potentiel de leur région comment ils
peuvent aider leurs régions et comment
ils peuvent amener
les entreprises à rester dans leur
région et puis il y en a d'autres qui ne
regardent que que l'argent à la fin à la
fin de l'année à la fin du mois à la fin
du mandat et voilà voilà je pense que
les choix se font comme ça c'est c'est
notre présence à nous les organisations
professionnelles proches des des élus
qui fait que ils vont faire des marchés
qui correspondent à leur territoire ou
alors notre éloignement de ces élus là
qui font que des fois ils pensent faire
bien mais pour nous c'est pas génial
des bêtises
un exemple toujours du véhicule là sur
le projet que je mène 8 millions hors
taxes de travaux sans entreprise
générale avec une entreprise générale
c'est plus 500000 euros de travaux et
donc en fait on a choisi une solution
macrolo en fait on a découpé les lots de
façon macro pour consulter les
entreprises mais on a là aussi le
bénéfice d'avoir une maîtrise d'oeuvre
qui est structurée avec aussi un OPC qui
va nous accompagner sur l'opération
voilà concernant les petites entreprises
nous on est pour la lotissement et avec
des lots clairement définies une
maîtrise d'oeuvre une conception tout à
fait compétente et présente et et du
coup la conception réalisation on n'est
pas dans ce schéma là ni les marchés
globaux on est vraiment sur les marchés
au lotis avec une bonne maîtrise
d'oeuvre et effectivement on peut on a
vu des cas pas mal de cas d'ailleurs où
c'était moins cher c'était moins cher
facialement comme ça c'est passé et puis
c'était aussi moins cher parce qu'il y
avait pas besoin de refaire des reprises
ou des chantiers supplémentaires
derrière parce que on n'avait pas mis le
prix de palais que le moins 10 ans amené
à finalement à devoir payer tôt ou tard
le coup que représente le moins de 10
ans à moyen terme parce qu'il faut
refaire des travaux puisque le compte
n'était pas au départ donc nous on est
plutôt pour des marchés où le mieux
disant et la lotissement sont sont bien
en place et avec une conception
merci beaucoup
on arrive à la fin du coup de notre
échange je te laisse nous vous
remercions encore une fois pour votre
disponibilité puis pour la richesse des
informations données nous ne manquerons
pas de vous faire part de la suite de
nos travaux à l'issue des conclusions
mais il nous reste encore de nombreuses
auditions et vous avez contribué à la
richesse de nos travaux aussi merci
beaucoup et bonne continuation merci à
vous merci merci à vous merci au revoir